- Please welcome Neve's Scream
Co-Star Melissa Barrera.
(upbeat music)
No, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no.
That's funny producers.
No, you know I don't like to be scared.
Get on outta here.
That was very clever producers.
Very clever, so funny, so funny.
Okay, let's try that again.
Cause I say no to that.
Please, I'm gonna have
nightmares, It's fine.
Please welcome Melissa
Barrera foreal please.
Oh my God, love your outfit!
- Thank you.
That was not my idea.
We've been doing press
together, so its okay.
- Oh my God, y'all can
sit near each other.
- That was not my idea.
- Your eyebrows are fabulous.
- Oh thank you.
- Jesus, I'd pay for those.
You kinda guess, but yeah, their so great.
- Let's get this out of the way,
'cause we are doing compliments.
How does it feel to have God's voice?
[Kelly Laughs]
- I didn't know where that was going.
- Its a genuine question.
- That is so nice, you're so nice.
- Your incredible.
- How does it feel to
be doing what you love?
I love that.
Do you all love that?
- Its incredible
- I feel like we all hit the lottery,
like especially creative people.
There's so many of us and to actually.
It's such a small percentage
that actually gets to do it.
I find that we're so lucky and blessed.
- I agree, I feel very fortunate.
And very fortunate to be
sitting on this couch with Neve.
- [Kelly] Oh my God I
just saw your hair thing.
- Look at that hair clip, I just saw that.
- [Kelly] Why are you
trying to scare me Melissa?
- I know
- That was your idea.
- Its pretty fab.
- Thank you.
- Was your idea, just kidding.
So did you watch Scream, like growing up?
Did you do it?
- I did, I grew up with Scream.
I was six when the first one came out.
So I did not watch it when I was six.
I would be traumatized.
- Your parents would be not great parents.
- No.
But I did.
I had a period of my life
when I was like 11 and 12.
Around that area, around that age.
That I was obsessed with scary movies.
So I discovered Scream
and a bunch of others.
All the Final Destinations and the,
What You Did Last Summers and all that.
And I was obsessed.
I've grown up with Ghostface.
- [Kelly] So you like them.
- I'm a masochist.
- Oh my God, what's wrong with you?
You don't get scared or like
have a problem falling asleep.
- All of the above.
I have to sleep with my light on.
- I had to quit watching Dateline.
Like that's how scared I get.
I'm like, oh my God, they
can get in the balcony,
on the third floor, what?
Your never safe.
- Funny thing I thought
Dateline was a dating show.
My entire life.
(Kelly laughs)
Whenever someone said.
I swear to God.
Whenever someone said
Dateline, I would always think.
Oh like a dating show,
that's on late at night.
In Mexico we don't have that.
So I just didn't know whatever that was.
- [Kelly] Its scary.
- But now I know.
- Now you do.
The more you know, okay there we go.
NBC, little NBC for you.
So Melissa, your Scream
Co-Star David Arquette taught.
Some of the casts.
I love this.
How to Bob Ross paint.
Is this true?
- It is true.
- He has many talents.
- He is, in Spanish we
say.(speaks foreign language)
- That was so sexy.
- He just like, knows
how to do lots of things
and has lots of hidden talents.
And he just showed up one day.
- [Kelly] Did you do that?
- [Melissa] I did that.
Look, we all did that.
Isn't that crazy.
- Did he teach y'all how to do that?
- He taught us how to do that.
He literally brought canvases
one day into our common room.
Which is what we had at the
hotel we were all staying in.
And he was like, I'm a
certified Bob Ross instructor.
And like, I was wondering
if you guys wanted to paint.
And we were all like, yes.
- I'm a certified Bob Ross.
I didn't know that was a thing.
- It is a thing.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- It's beautiful because it
was very metaphorical in like.
It's all about relaxing and like flowing
and like, not trying too hard.
Like having fun with it.
I feel like that's why
people love Bob Ross.
And he, was such an art
teacher just going around
and being like, go like this.
And I'm such a try hard.
Like, I'm just like.
- A perfectionist
A perfectionist and
like, and so I was like.
I would look over and like.
Jack and Jasmine were like bloop.
And it would look great and I'd be like.
And I would just like,
try to make it look good.
- You will feel good if you go with me.
I did one class where
it's someone's birthday.
And we did it and there was wine involved.
And so I was like, it's close enough.
Mine was the worst one.
I cannot paint.
There was a whole teacher helping.
God could have come down from
the heavens and helped me.
And it still wouldn't have worked out.
- Isn't that the beauty
of painting though?
Like haven't you seen those
videos where they're like.
Which one was made by
a professional painter.
And which one was made
by a three-year-old.
And you do not know.
You would know.
- Oh you would.
You would know, you would
know, you would know.
It's bad.
Do you paint?
Did you paint.
No gosh no, I wish I
wish, but I'm like you.
Like hopless.
- I can't, I tried so hard.
And then finally just
leaned into the red wine.
Maybe this will help me.
And my ex like his was beautiful.
Yours was beautiful.
Why you staring at me there.
Everybody's looks so beautiful.
Like that picture in mine was just like.
Which one of these is not like the other.
Anyway, so you had your start in reality
and unreality competition show.
Congratulations we both did.
- I did not win.
You won.
- We're still here.
We won.
That's crazy. I didn't know that.
- I did, it was like a weird,
like a famous show in Mexico.
That's a mixture of American
Idol and Big Brother.
So it's brutal.
You basically are under surveillance.
You're living in a house with
all the other contestants
during the week.
And you're preparing for
the live shows on Sundays.
But I met my husband
there, so that was amazing.
- Oh, wow.
That worked out in so many forms.
- That's probably the reason
that I had to go on that show.
- That's amazing.